measures of central tendency now in
probability and statistics we met
measures of central tendency or measures
center a long time ago because they're
not complicated ideas there's three of
them they all start with M what other
main mode making very good ok so mean
mode median we tend to spend a lot of
time on the mean the average because um
you know it often is very useful to us
you can use it in a variety of
situations and it's often very
meaningful but it's not without its
problems we have other ones here the
mode of the median which had their own
distinct like helpful things depend on
the kind of data that you have for
example like if you've got categorical
data which is you know words that can't
necessarily be ordered neatly it's not
ordinal you can't do a mean or median
there's no calculation to do between
those kinds of things you just have to
say what's the most popular one okay and
with median the reason why we're
interested in these guys is because
unlike the average the median is not
subject to outliers do you remember that
right if there's a group of us 20 of us
and we all earn like $50,000 a year and
then there's one person who earns like
there's a Jeff Bezos in the root is like
I earn trillions of dollars right he
throws out the average completely the
mean is meaningless in a situation like
that okay so we use the median okay
because it would ignore an outlier like
that Shh
so what are these mode mean and median
look like in the context of probability
density functions we've met one of these
already the mode this is the first one
we're going to do but I only dealt with
it with some of you as we were going
around some people ask this question
because they got to it in the exercise
and some people didn't so let's just
make sure we're on the same track here
and the mode is what like what's our
definition for the mode in a data set
most common most frequent right now when
it comes to probability because it's a
probability density functions right most
common is going to imply therefore
highest probability does that make sense
most the most common thing it's like are
them
common color of hair in this room it's
black so that's also the most probable
thing if I were to pick one out of
random
so highest probability so what I'm
looking for is what's the maximum value
on my probability density functions that
makes sense now quickly under this we
won't deal with this one in detail
because it's actually another one that
is the new concept depending on what
your probability density function looks
like you will find the highest
probability which is the mode in
different ways and I hope this rings
some bells for example you might have
data that looks like that right you
might have a probability density
function that looks like this how do you
find the maximum here it's going to be
at the turning point do you agree so the
turning point is where you might find
the maximum provided it's concave down
right it's like oh look this is the
concave down basically what if you had a
concave up I wouldn't be very useful to
write on that if you had for example a
probability density function that looked
like say this okay you can have probably
didn't see functions that look like
anything really
okay in this case you've got a minimum
here so that's not gonna help you that's
not clearly not the highest probability
in fact it's the lowest okay
so I'm not gonna look for a stationary
point here what am I gonna look for what
we call this guy here right it's on the
it's on the ends isn't it it's on one of
the boundary values right so I would say
oh it's an end point not a turning point
that gives me my maximum does that make
sense
and then still again sometimes you may
have something like you're sure to think
of it example for you okay so what do
you got here actually I'll make this a
bit lower just to make it more obvious
for you okay at this point right here
you do have a maximum but it's not the
maximum is that we have language for
this right rather than saying a and B
and we would call this no what we call
it we would call it the dust-up with an
L actually the local maximum all the all
the relative maximum it's like
this little vicinity it's the it's the
local max but what I'm looking for
really
is the glory wall max which in this case
happens an M pointing it said again yes
this is this is just the local max I'm
really interested in the in the global
Max he's um he's the one I'm interested
in okay so all these ways to say oh okay
mode I know what that must mean for
probability and so therefore I know what
it means for the probability density
function okay now that's that's not a
new idea
there is the new one I really want to
have a look at and has some implications
for our our integration and stuff like
that today it's the median will visit
the mean later on okay so you told me
the mode is the most frequent one what's
the median what's our what's our will
definition it's the middle score right
the middle score I think about that
means for a second put your put your
pens down okay if I put us into a high
order okay and I said what is the median
what is the median height okay how do I
determine that on the basis of a
probability density function let's think
about this okay let's just let's just
say for the sake of argument right
suppose I am the median height in this
classroom
okay so we're all in order okay so the
show this person is on this side of the
room the tall person is on this side of
the room okay so if I am the median
height I'm right in the middle so half
the classes over here half the classes
over there okay now the total
probability density function of all of
us adds up to one right so think
carefully it's not a rhetorical question
if I now said put all your names in a
hat draw one out at random what's the
probability that we're going to draw
someone on the shorter end of the room
it's going to be a half right because
that's half of the room what about the
probability that we get someone the
taller so also half because it has to be
half plus half do you agree okay so
think about this this has implications
for this is what I wanted right
what does anyone remember what's our
notation for the median we haven't
because I won't don't want to keep on
writing median
it's um it's a bit of too straight it's
it's q2 because it's one of the
quartiles do you remember those guys the
quartiles first quartile third quartile
the median is the middle one the second
quartile okay so if the court the the
median the second quartile is the middle
score right think about this what is the
probability how do I state that in terms
of an integral of getting say the
shorter half of the class hmm think
think I've got to start from the
shortest person in the class right now
think the QQ one's a different quartile
right it's gonna be wherever your data
starts right do you agree with that
whoever your shortest person is okay
so you start at the shorter person in
the class and then you go up to your
medium right now if you integrate over
that domain what should you get that's
one half of the class right so the
probability should be 1/2 do you agree
with that does that make sense
ah and so this is the short half of the
class in exactly the same way I can say
for the for the tall half of the class
I'm gonna start at the median and then
I'm going to go to whoever the tall this
person is right which is it's probably
the global max ironically so I'm going
to go all the way up to the top okay to
the tallest person and if I again
integrate over that okay I screwed it
again equal ha does this make sense